now for the first time Parliament in  Council met for electronic signature we  will send it directly the regulation  measures to suffer that the security of  gas supply which will use the momentum  the Estonian presidency to promote more  digital solutions in the future we must  ensure that the public administration in  the whole of Europe goes digital and  follows the god example of a stone today  for the first time we are signing a  European legal act electronically it is  a small step for an Estonian but it's  potentially a giant leap for European  administration's and it is certainly  something for the EU digital history  books the e-signature we affixed today  will have the same legal validity as a  handwritten signature I'm convinced that  this is the way we will soon sign all  our legal acts it simply makes sense a  signature saves time saves money and  saves paper